el candidato presidencial que Mike oglu
tiene esperanza de impedir la reelección
del ultraconservador
en esa carrera uno de los temas
centrales es el de las relaciones
internacionales
es muy importante para nosotros y para
todo el mundo llegar a un acuerdo de paz
entre Rusia y Ucrania pero debemos dejar
Claro que no consideramos correcto que
ningún país ocupe las tierras de otro
virus
ha elevado el tono contra Rusia además
la acusa de interferir en las elecciones
a favor del presidente erdoan el kremlin
respondió
no hay interferencia de ningún tipo y si
alguien le ha proporcionado al Señor esa
información son mentirosos
por su parte
menos contundente con la invasión dice
que apoya la paz y es el principal
promotor del acuerdo de granos que
Desbloquea los puertos ucranianos pero
Ucrania no es el único foco
centro del extinto imperio otomano la
Turquía moderna sigue influyendo en sus
países vecinos incluida una Siria en
guerra
con el progresivo retorno del país de
bashara la Sad a la política
internacional Damasco y ankara enemigos
Por años están relanzando sus relaciones
así lo mostró la Cumbre del 10 de mayo
en Moscú que también incluyó a Irán
imágenes que le dieron la vuelta al
mundo
miles de refugiados sirios salen de las
costas turcas hacia la Unión Europea la
Turquía Rey jeftaib erdoan tiene un rol
protagónico como muro invisible por eso
desde 2012 Bruselas le ha girado ankara
cerca de 3.340 millones de euros para
financiar ayuda humanitaria a casi 4
millones de refugiados sirios en Turquía
a cambio el gobierno de erdogan Se
comprometió a contener la migración
irregular
la relación entre Turquía y la Unión
Europea ha sido ambivalente y este
domingo las elecciones podrían rediseñar
esa relación
[Música]